hay que remarcar que las tensiones que
llevaron la caída de bashir en abril del
2019 que inició el proceso de transición
que ya se está
cayendo está fracasando subsisten por
ejemplo en 2020 el inflación fue más del
150% en sudán y de hecho en las
protestas contra va a seguir en un ciclo
que ya había comenzado a fines de 2018
saldaron con más 200 muertos y se
iniciaron presuntamente por el precio de
un insumo tan básico para sectores
populares como el pan eso llevó la a las
protestas que quisieron poner la
renuncia en abril de 2019 también la
sociedad sigue dividida pero yo diga que
hay un mayor apoyo a los sectores
civiles que son los que salieron a
protestar hoy ya se hablan de más de 80
heridos y al menos tres muertes ya
producto de las heridas la transición se
había establecido por un periodo tres
años es una claro retroceso
truncar esa transición que había
planteado también desde el 17 noviembre
a dar a hand of land planeaba ya la
vuelta a un gobierno totalmente civil
porque el consejo básico de transición
consejo soberano es más bien una
incómoda un incómodo encuentro entre
fuerzas civiles y militar